Speaker 1: All right. Give you a quick update
on the Herschel Walker, Raphael Warnock runoff,
December six, of course, in Georgia. This will
determine not who controls the Senate. Democrats
have taken control of the Senate. It is currently
5249. But that race, that runoff will determine
is it a 5050 Senate for two years where Kamala
Harris is the tie breaking vote for Democrats,
or will Democrats have a 51 to 49 majority, which
at least takes care of Joe Manchin or Kirsten
Cinema without requiring Kamala Harris's tie
breaking vote? Herschel Walker continues to speak,
and it becomes increasingly clear every time
he does that he doesn't have any idea what
is going on. Herschel Walker held it. It's
truly beyond parody at this point in time.
WALKER Her Walker held an event in which he I
think he's trying to attack Raphael Warnock here,
but he really is criticizing himself. You'll see
what I mean in a moment here. In this first clip,
Herschel Walker addressing the issue of
keeping one's own kids, keeping one's own kids.
Speaker 2: And then you paint himself with
child care and all that stuff while he keeps
his own. Kids don't have nobody to keep your
kid. You keep your kid. He's got somebody else
keep I keep my own even though he lied about me.
It's okay. It's okay because you try to get your
vote. Don't let it trick you try to get your vote.
Speaker 1: What is Herschel Walker talking about
right there? Is Herschel Walker saying that
Raphael Warnock should parent his children?
Because one of the things we learned about
Herschel Walker is that he's been an absent father
to multiple kids. Or am I make trying to make
more sense of it than we can make? Let's listen
to this again. What is he talking about?
Speaker 2: And then you paid himself with
child care and all that stuff. Why did
he keep his own kids? Don't have nobody
to keep your kid. To keep your kid. He's
got somebody else. Him. I keep my own,
even though he lied about me. It's okay. It's
okay. Because you try to get your vote. Don't
let it trick. You try to get your vote.
Speaker 1: How can you hear that and think
that's someone who should be making
decisions about what our tax rates should be?
That's somebody who I would want to be
one of 100 votes for the entire country.
As to decisions on foreign policy, it just
doesn't make any sense. Literally, it doesn't
make any sense. Here's one more clip at another
event where Herschel Walker yesterday is. I mean,
I guess I don't even know how to report on
this. I guess he's trying to make the case
that he would be a good senator. Fundamentally,
that's what this is about. And he attacked the
green agenda and said that we should continue
having gas guzzling cars. And it's not clear
whether he doesn't understand gas guzzling as
a pejorative or whether he likes it. You know,
some of these people love the idea of damaging
the environment. They sort of take pride in it.
They say it's manly and patriotic. Listen to this.
And again, try to make heads or tails out of it.
Speaker 2: And probably you are in Russia
and they're not talking about trying to
charge a take out in a desert and
talk about war. And let me tell
you this. Even if we were ready for the
green agenda, I raise my hand right now,
but we're not ready right now. So don't let them
fool you that this is a new agenda. This is not
a new agenda. We're not prepared. We're not ready
right now. What we need to do is keep damn old gas
guzzling cars. So we got the good emission down
and owned car was the best thing that we can.
But we need help. We need help. And those are the
people that help us change that. Helping us any
you're not helping us, but yeah, we're going to
do it all. But he's spending your money and it.
Speaker 1: Doesn't make any sense. I know that
most of those words are English, but it doesn't
make any sense. And the hope is, if Herschel
Walker's lack of qualifications are made clear,
if Herschel Walker's hypocrisy on so many issues
is made clear. And if we do the door knocking and
we do the phone banking and to the extent that you
do need to raise money in order to win a Senate
seat, people donate to Raphael Warnock. Hopefully
this goes in Warnock's favor. I continue to say
it would be such a massive humiliation to the
country, to the country to see Herschel Walker
be a senator. That we really need to pull out
all the stops and prevent it from happening.
And by the way, we're going to be up against Kelly
Lefler. You tell me whether that's scary or not.